hello everyone I'm Joseph Carmichael  Otis is  was my father but we are not here today  to mourn his death but to celebrate his  life  we knew Otis as a teacher a community  leader a role model a husband and a  father now I thought it would be nice to  share something about him you all may  not have known when my father was  younger he was an actor in Hollywood  going through my dad's things I found  this reel of his work as an actor I  haven't seen it yet but I thought it  would be fun to watch here all of you  today  oh where are my pies Ribble's where are  the pies I put on my windowsill well I  don't know mrs. gerado why would anyone  wanna steal Wario  delicious blueberry hey see to it to  shine those shoes up nice boy yes sir  you best people leaving I will I'll  shine your shoes Oh  in 1964 my father marched with Martin  Luther King jr. and Harry Belafonte  along with other renowned civil rights  leaders